krusty-krab continues cartoon crime up
constantly commencing with the
contradictory controversial and
counterfeit comedic cape
also the side post made of bones like
spongebob serial killer pants am i right
the anchor in this reflection takes up
much more space on the hat than the lawn
on his spongy head also out of these
hats even stay on to the inhabitants of
Bikini Bottom have some sort of head
phallus to hold it in place that I have
to think special thoughts so it stays
secure the law of conservation of mass
is often simplified as matter cannot be
created or destroyed but if you read the
fine print it also says that a plate of
hamburgers cannot be turned into both a
pizza and a box the pizza comes in also
if this is a door for the heads there
had better be a door for the tails or
since you're underwater you could just
you know go over the what was that hey
Liam why is this voice higher that would
mean that these tires should float l
regular air should make these tires
float tires would need to be made of
heavy stone to make any sense for the
bottom of the ocean ha making sense this
show makes less sense than a foreclosed
penny factory shut in the air and be
escaping from SpongeBob's entire person
he's a exponent right oh yeah reverse
spongebob is hallucinating the actual
Korean words for forward and backward
here which means his brain actually
knows Korean and he should still
understand which way to go or where the
arrows could help
at least it can't get any worse but it
immediately does cliche also how does
this boat without a driver even stay on
the route Wow
I mean you're not walking on the road
[Music]
I'm not saying this roadside dance is
racist but I am saying Squidward's nose
looks like a penis convenient pizza
shoot is convenient actual footage of
the writer is getting distracted during
TV since staff meetings somehow makes it
into the show even if spongebob 'yes but
splits like this while I was pants all
jammed up in there like they want to go
spunk holes belonging
Razi BOM has this voice in his arsenal
and he still chooses to use his
high-pitched squeaky voice Raj is this a
good time to tell Squidward that
spongebob has been eating this entire
time you know considering sponges filter
food through their entire body from the
water around them sure as a fine yeah
hold on there were more pepperoni slices
on this pizza earlier poo am I kidding
they hold this pizza box vertically half
the time so this entire intact pizza the
law absolutely horrifying at what point
does cartoon physics just turn into
Nightmare fuel because I'm thinking
during a being in half might across that
line also even if his body can somehow
merge back together how does the Hat
reattach dear god this show is an
underwater acid trip if it ends with
Squidward wearing a bear suit and a
flaming pineapple I honestly wouldn't be
surprised
wow this one's on how's it still
daylight when they began this adventure
it was dark outside about water or ocean
whatever it is it's not right
for a while this final line was censored
from TV because tentacles sound too much
like testicles and honestly anyone who
was going to be that overly sensitive
can go right ahead and suck my conch
Pizza Delivery for uh IC wiener make
sure you click that Bell icon but
clicking the little bell icon is how you
make sure you get notified every time we
release a video
[Music]
how did we get into this mess we seem to
be made to suffer I heard in times of
hardship the Pioneers would eat coral
that's where I see things just a little
differently contractor no I will not bow
to any sponsor no hey you uh you're the
one that ordered the large meat pizza
yeah